me and Connor just came back from Korea
we wanted to talk about it I guess
please what do you think Conor it was
your first time so uh it was cool it was
swag and that's the end of trash T guys
thanks it was it was uh it was nice uh a
lot of things I liked some things I
didn't like as much you know let's let's
run through it what did you like what
did you not like okay okay I I I got to
get I got to get this he's going to tell
me I I got to come out all right it's
trash sh I got to come out swinging
because I was I think I've mentioned
this take before and now I've been to
Korea other times uh like more times now
I genuinely believe that Korean barbecue
is better in the states yeah like I I
have gone to three different Korean
barbecue places in Korea now and they've
I've always not so much been
disappointed but more so I've gone to
them and I'm like this is good but I
felt like my experience I I was like I
know what Peak is and Peak is like
Korean barbecue in LA and I think I also
agree with you on that like it's not to
say that Korean barbecue is bad
necessarily it's fantastic but like I
don't know what it is is it the cuts of
the meat is it the way they cook it is
it the marinade I don't know what it is
but there's just something about the
meat they use in American Korean
barbecue that is just it just is more
pleasing to my
palet and I don't know why I I like all
you can eat I'm I like all you can eat
and in Korea a lot of them were not all
you can eat true yeah I mean were there
are a lot of O can eat uh Korean
barbecues in Korea but I feel like I
don't know sometimes like the vibe is
different because you get it almost felt
like every Korean barbecue place I went
to there was less choice of like the
different cuts there like three Cuts in
this one place I went to that was it it
was like PA only three yeah they
specialized in like those cards and it
was fine it was pretty good yeah what
what the thing I see in Korean barbecues
in Korea is very much more it's more
reminiscent of like the Yaki Yaki niku
kind of experience where you have these
like very specialized yeah it's kind of
I would almost say Korean barbecue in
Korea is kind of like the in between of
Japanese Yakiniku and like American
cream barbecue if that makes sense like
there's elements to Yaki niku where it's
like the meat cuts are more specialized
as you said but it also is I guess a lot
more I don't want to say flavorful like
American Korean barbecue but like what
what's the word like you know what I
mean like it's it's when you eat Yaki
niku it's heavy for sure because you're
eating a shitload of meat but like it
doesn't leave you with that feeling of
like oh God kind of deal you know no I'd
win
huh I'd win every time i' win I don't
get that feeling when I when I have the
meat yeah no meat makes me feel light
it's like stop when I eat a [__] ton of
meat I feel
good what do you mean what is this like
controversial tast yes yes I feel way
worse if I have like a Ramen well yeah
because you're EA that's like starch and
uh salt yeah well obviously but like how
how do you not feel like like it's not
so much like okay cuz like when you eat
ramen it's the kind of like feeling of
full where it's you're bloated right
obviously because you've had a lot of
starch you've had a lot of carbs and
then you you know and then the noodles
obviously expand in your stomach when
you have you know the ramen like broth
and like water and stuff like that right
but with meat it's just it's a lot it is
it's a lot of food I've never been to a
Korean barbecue in America at least and
I have like especially if it's all you
can eat and you get to a point where you
know okay here's here's the big question
here's here the big question do you
order rice you go to an or you can eat
place you can order as much meat as you
can do you order rice I try to stay away
from it yeah I try to only meet the
system yeah so normally normally I try
to get a little bit of rice but most of
the time when I go to an or you can eat
crean barbecue place I eat only meat dud
I eat a [__] lot of rice and you get to
that point because it works well with
the rice that's Point how they get you
no no that's okay that's like going to
like a he call me niin I like my rice
that's that's that's like going to a
buffet and having the pizza crust when
you have like all you can eat pizza
that's just like wasted space wasted
spacee with that first of all I eat the
cross because I'm not a [__] child no
okay especially in an all you can eat
buffet cross is just empty like cross is
just wasted stomach space I swear to God
okay we're not we're not going to
entertain your baby opinion on that
let's let's stay on topic right okay
staying on topic you eat enough meat and
I remember like you just get like the
meat sweats do you guys know what I'm
talking about you guys talking I get
like I get a little bit of that but I
don't get it that bad and I kind of like
that you like the meat sweats I like
sweating when I eat
meat wait hold on it's satisfying do you
did you have to say it like that yes I
did I like sweating when I eat meat I
like sweating when Goblin down
meat because I I always enjoy the
feeling of just eating a [__] ton of
meat but I always regret it the moment I
outside why do you regret it because
it's just a lot of [__] meat yeah but
that's it's just a lot man no that's not
a regret sweats start kicking in you're
just like oh God what I only regret that
I had weakness and I and I had to stop I
wanted to keep
going why are you laughing I'm serious
just really funny imagining you step out
of a koream barbecue sweating your nuts
off and you're like damn it feels good I
know I like I like it cuz that means I
ate a good amount of meat [__] you know
you don't like that
no okay I don't I don't say I don't like
it obviously I I love eating meat pause
but I don't like the feeling that you
get after you've had like a shitload of
meat you know like there's there's a
there's a good amount of meat you can
have where you feel satisfied and you
don't get the sweats you know but when
you go to a Korean barbecue or even a
yakin niku I never not have that because
the option to have as much meat as you
possibly can is more satisfying okay I
don't know this is thing when I go to
yakin niku even if it's like or you can
order or you can eat I always you can
order if you can say it you can have it
well 20 plates I'm not going to eat any
oh that's that's how I think about it
because I don't know why I always come
out of Yaki Niki and I feel like I've
eaten like I I get like reasonably full
even if even if it's all you can eat for
some reason when I go to Korean barbecue
I always [__] stuff myself to the
Limit and should I think that's just a
personal taste issue though I don't know
why I think you just prefer Korean
barbecue over Yakiniku I mean
also in Japan when you when you go to
Yakiniku a lot of the times the portions
are quite small so even when you're
ordering a lot of meat it's only quite
small so it's really hard to actually
just get through it cuz they're bringing
it quite slowly odds are you're eating
it way faster than they're bringing it
out yeah I think that's the big thing I
like about America as well when when you
order a portion of meat they give you
they slap down an entire [__] massive
PL much sometimes though and I just feel
bad for wasting it cuz I look at this
like leftover pile of I'm sweating just
dripping down that's where the meat
sweat sh I have to eat that usually some
places in America do this though they
charge you if you don't eat uh some some
of the meat yeah you do that thing where
you kind of put it all put it on the
grill you're like ah maybe it'll like
disintegrate in the corner you're like
it's like if I Char it down enough and I
shove it it on this thing no no that's
the Strat when uh that's not with like
Korean barbecue but hot pot that's like
if you go to melt into the if you can
all if you go to an or you can eat a hot
pot you're like [__] how do we get rid
of all of the [__] that we ordered uh I
mean meat kind of like crank the heat up
meat shrinks if you leave in water for
long enough right oh by the way MCH oh
oh yeah yeah yeah I mean we obviously
said it at the beginning of the episode
but hey we got M we said at the
beginning we said at the beginning of
the episode did [__] sorry yeah we said
but we can shout it out again check it
out I I could eat a lot of meat in this
and be
comfortable stretchy it is stretchy
insane quality you went crazy yeah I
wanted to thank Joey for this one
because he has this merch drop is crazy
yeah available for limited time as we
mentioned Link in the description yeah
it's so comfy I'm glad but you can
finally see con wearing something else
sweat now you get meat sweats just
thinking about it think about it but I
also I also think another thing about
Korean barbecue that I enjoy in America
as well um is I don't know if this is
just the barbecue places that I went to
in career as well but I feel like they
have different like Bogi and G that they
give you as well there's just so much
more different choices not only of the
cuts one day I'll figure out what
bulgogi is isn't it just Mar isn't it
just the name of a marinade I don't know
I don't
know there's just there's just every
kind of combination of all the sources
and all the cuts that you can think of
in America and in Korea it's just very
at least from my experience very very
much more limited maybe it was just the
places I went to but it was three
different places I went to we also had
fried chicken one night and it was
pretty bad I think we went to a bad
place yeah I think that was just the
place that we went to so me and Sydney
actually walked past that place and I
didn't notice this so we stayed in uh
hung was it it was like very tourist
very touristy so I think we just went to
a tourist trap because definitely we
definitely did yeah yeah because I I had
uh fried chicken with Sydney like
afterwards is where I stayed for a few
more days and it [__] slapped it was
it was great um but I
I I walked past the place that me and
Connor went to and I saw it um because
we ate here on the very first day we
literally just landed we were just like
let's go to a chicken place found the
first chicken place sure it like the
only place that could fit like a big
group right right and I saw they had a
sign and I didn't and now I know this is
a guaranteed tourist trap right cuz I
know I saw I had a sign and it said
Gordon Ramsay recommends this chicken
place and I was just like no [__] way
Gordon Ramsey actually recommends this
particular chicken place and uh Emily
accidentally ordered like five times the
amount of chicken we needed why did she
do this every time so literally they it
was like it was like a meme it just kept
coming out we we had like and it wasn't
even that good yeah yeah we had like we
had like like 30 pieces of chicken left
over and I was like Emily why did you
order this much he's like why didn't
they tell me this was too much I was
like I feel like the hus is on you here
Emily not them yeah yeah it was great
because uh you know the only person who
could speak just a little bit of Korean
was Emily so we kind of just left
everything to her yeah how was it the
one person that can speak the language
[__] up the order well she was over
over well she she overestimated because
she was expecting Japanese portions uh
but we soon found out that Japanese
portions and Korean portions are very
very very different never Chang um and
then we you know we had like 30 more
pieces of chicken then we could possibly
eat and then we were we went to a craft
Place afterwards and we were just like
let's order a pizza as well cuz we're on
holiday did you get the meat sweats uh
we got the pizza sweats after the pizza
we like okay okay Emily Emily we would
like to order the small size of the
pizza and like a [__] meme somehow
something got Lost in Translation and
they brought out the biggest size of the
pizza 18 in it was an 18
in I was like Emily come on what the
[__] when when do you realize that you
she might purposely be doing this maybe
just to [__] with you guys